[Music]
yeah they can't stop and wonder why
Bleeker look at me
what if this time I didn't go back you
gave stark your wire girl to give it to
you you know we both made promises not
to each other stay
stay
you have the power to destroy the stock
you must do it one priest
we are out of time it's not fair it
shouldn't be you but it is it's alright
you could never hurt me
[Music]
you think I'm a child of Ultron I'm not
all true I'm not Java silent I am
[Music]
you're afraid of you of death well the
last one you're unbearably naive well I
was born yesterday
[Music]
I looked in your head and saw
annihilation look again
[Music]
I just feel you
[Music]
you want me to help you put Jarvis into
this thing no of course not I want to
help you put Jarvis in this thing
[Music]
I'm sorry that was odd
thank you I am on the side of life
Ultron isn't it he will end it all
what's he waiting for you where sokovia
I'm sorry did you it's as I said
catastrophe
I get first crack at the big guy
my man's when he's waiting for that's
true he hates you the most maybe I am a
monster so there may be no way to make
you trust me but we need to go
or not if I'm overstepping
[Music]
I have to go pinch of pepper again a
pinch set pepper Nikesh I thought it
might lift your spirits to a
sufficiently powerful energy source
something very similar to its own
signature pounds its molecular integrity
good faith and you with it
this said I became distracted I think
that was possible
neither did I
clicked
you can't overpower me I know it
[Music]
it stopped me from facie spirits lifted
in my defense i i haven't actually ever
eaten anything before please we talked
about this yes but the door was open so
I assumed that Captain Rogers wished to
know when mr. stock was a rider thank
you
beer it down I'll use the door Ultron
[Music]
you set the tongue so you can change
them alright you shut me out
you think I care whatever form that
takes I'm game you're saying they'll
come for me we would protect you
maybe Tony's
no it's a involuntary response in the
amygdala they can't help but be afraid
of you are you my amygdala is synthetics
[Music]
[Music]
Captain Rogers
[Music]
[Music]
the structure has polymorphic right we
had to attach each neuron on
non-sequential why didn't you just
reprogram the synapses to work
collectively because we didn't think of
it I'm sure you did your best
[Music]
[Music]
what is this leave your thoughts and
feelings in the comments below
reminder about the giveaway if you'd
like to enter for your chance to win a
copy of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
a special edition poster and some
special memorabilia from our partners at
silk and cotton all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
[Music]